we begin this morning with renewed
demands and renewed demonstrations for
congress to tighten gun legislation tens
of thousands of people are expected to
march in washington and more than 400
other cities in the u.s for the march
for our lives following the recent mass
shootings in new york and texas caitlin
huey burns is at the white house with
the latest this morning caitlin good
morning and welcome to the show
good morning michelle good to be with
you well thousands of activists are
going to be gathered here in washington
and in 450 cities across the country in
the wake of shootings in uvalde and
buffalo the group is being act being
organized by march for our lives which
was founded in the wake of the parkland
shooting in 2018 and
and one of the founders of march for our
lives we don't want to send our kids to
school in bulletproof backpacks and to
schools that look like prisons in a
preview of today's rally activists laid
out
2280 school books and broken pencils on
the washington mall representing the
number of children that have been killed
by gun violence in the last 14 months
such activism has led to some changes to
gun laws at the state level but federal
legislation has long been elusive to me
the glass is half full
i am optimistic at this moment on this
vote the yeas are 223
the nays are 204 this week the house
passed a broad package of bills that
includes raising the minimum age to
purchase a semi-automatic rifle to 21. a
ban on high-capacity magazines and a
so-called red flag law that would allow
courts to take away weapons from those
deemed to be a danger to themselves or
to others the bill stands no chance of
passing the evenly divided senate but a
bipartisan group of senators say they're
making progress on a more narrow set of
reforms i think focusing on
concerns about mental health
and on people with criminal
background records is an
obvious area where i think we can work
together this week lawmakers heard
soul-crushing testimony from a uvalde
survivor and a mother who lost her child
we stand for lexi
and as her voice we demand action he
shot my friend that was next to me
and i
thought he was gonna come back to the
room so i grabbed the blood
and
and put it all on me
and those testifying on capitol hill are
another example about how those left
behind by gun violence are often thrust
into activism now senate negotiators say
that they are hopeful they can hammer
out a deal in the next couple of weeks
that can actually be signed into law but
we know that the biggest impediment to
any such deal is often the passage of
time and that's why activists gathered
here in washington say they're trying to
keep the pressure on dana
all right caitlyn those young young
survivors so emotional in that testimony
thank you very much